new this morning the TSA has topped last
year's record number of guns found at
airport checkpoints screeners spotted
more than 4,000 firearms in carry-on
bags so far this year nearly 300 were
found in Atlanta's hartsfield-jackson
International Airport alone last year
the TSA saw the numbers jump 17% more
than eight out of ten guns were loaded
we've been investigating these incidents
for the past eight months to try to
understand why this is happening Kris
Van Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
outside of Washington DC Chris good
morning good morning we have been
sifting through police records from 2017
and in almost every case people say this
was a mistake they simply forgot or
didn't realize the gun was in that
carry-on bag 239 airports found guns
last year many of the airports that
found the most are in states with looser
gun laws but we found some things that
are raising real questions this morning
about airport security a loaded gun
inside a fliers carry-on bag at
dallas-fort Worth Airport it's a scene
that played out thousands of times last
year at TSA checkpoints across the
country at a rate of nearly 11 guns a
day store you buy online
okay so on that floor CBS News obtained
video from security cameras in police
body cams at DFW Airport showing some of
the 211 incidents where a gun was found
inside a traveler's bag at a TSA
checkpoint in 2017 in this 59 year-olds
carry-on bag police found a loaded
pistol and several additional magazines
loaded with what police say was 61
rounds of ammunition in Texas that'll
get you arrested if you don't have a
license to carry a concealed weapon but
laws vary by state
hands behind your back please just 10
airports accounted for nearly a third of
all incidents last year through Freedom
of Information requests we were able to
review police records from seven of them
the vast majority of the people involved
are men 63 percent were white most
ranged in age from their 30s to their
50s but guns were found in the luggage
of an 84 year old woman a ten year old
boy an airport worker and a pastor from
Texas who told police he forgot the gun
was in his backpack
Colorado State Representative lori saine
spent a night in jail after a gun was
found in her purse at Denver
International Airport they said right
away I'm sorry I forgot I'm a mistake
and and that's when I was cuffed she was
ultimately not criminally charged but
did receive a nearly $2,000 fine from
the TSA hopefully this is a learning
experience for others not to make the
mistake in the first place the agency
can seek fines up to $13,000 in press
releases TSA says a typical first
offense draws a thirty nine hundred
dollar fine but we found on average it's
actually closer to 1100 no one last year
received the maximum TSA administrator
David pukowski the fine could be 3,900
or $4,000 but no one ever pays that on
occasion they do though we're trying to
provide that that warning if you will
that hey there is there is a penalty
here and if we can prevent it in the
first place I think that's a better
better way to approach it a review of
the police documents reveals at least
three incidents last year where it
appears the gun was missed by TSA
screeners at one Airport and only
discovered on the person's trip home how
does that happen
it happens because the technology
doesn't get everything all the time
either there's a technology issue
there's a procedural issue or there's a
training issue and a little troubled by
the fact that the gun went through the
x-ray machine and was missed
oh I'm troubled by that too I think
everybody in TSA is troubled by it and
mistakes happen
how often do those mistakes happen I
can't give you an answer as to how often
it happens but when it does happen we do
everything we can to figure out why it
happened
the TSA is starting to roll out new CT
scanners to checkpoints that should make
it easier for screeners to spot weapons
the agency is also working with airports
to try to improve signage around
checkpoints reminding people you cannot
bring a gun through and while there are
procedures for having a gun in your
checked bag you can never have a weapon
loaded or unloaded in your carry-on bag
all of the people you saw in our story
told police they did not realize the gun
was in the bag they brought to a
checkpoint biana just mind boggling
watching that great reporting Chris
thank you